hello everyone
thank you for tuning in to our panel
discussion on fairness and ai
we're looking forward to spending the
next 40 minutes or so
talking about some of the most pressing
and interesting themes
in the field of fairness in artificial
intelligence
and we'll also be taking advantage of
the expertise
across a number of amazon scientists and
scholars
working on different challenges in ai
and ml
let's kick things off with some
instructions
to start my name is natalie cephus
and i am an applied science manager at
aws
ai there i work to establish
scientifically rigorous benchmarking and
testing methods
for machine learning services ensuring
that the technology
produces results that are highly
accurate and most importantly
fair i started my machine learning
journey
at mississippi state university a
bachelor's degree in computer
engineering
and then i studied at georgia tech where
i earned my doctorate
in electrical and computer engineering
since then
i've spent more than a decade doing
research in the field of ai
and ml including being cto of a startup
company
that was acquired by amazon in 2016
the name of the startup company was part
pic based in atlanta georgia
so i have a keen interest in the topic
of fairness
in the ai industry and my team and i
are focused on training algorithms on
well-balanced
diverse ethically sourced and correctly
annotated data sets
it's similar to how using a calculator
to solve a math problem
doesn't guarantee you that you'll get
the right answer
as my middle school math teacher used to
say
all right so i'm looking forward to this
panel
um erin i'll pass it over to you
thanks natalie um so my name is erin
roth
i'm a professor at the university of
pennsylvania
and i'm also a amazon scholar at amazon
which is a
part-time role and in that role i
support uh
various amazon projects thinking about
fairness and privacy
and my background is in theoretical
computer science uh in particular
aspects of machine learning uh privacy
and and recently fairness
my phd was in differential privacy but
in the last
five or six years i've gotten really
interested in fairness and machine
learning
and aside from the fact this is a
pressing and important problem i think
this is a really
interesting area of research because
despite the sort of
um you know let's say volume and
velocity
of work over the last five or six years
i think we still really know very little
um
you know and it's a place where
definitions are important you know it's
easy to call something fairness but
but you know thinking about what that
really means to
downstream users is tricky to get right
and
um you know i'm happy to be here here at
amazon getting to think about these
questions
thanks aran uh i'll go next uh hi all my
name is rahul gupta
i am a science manager at alexa
and i work with the team that focuses on
privacy and fairness
as well my background is
i joined the team about four years back
i joined as a scientist
and i was working on alexa score
capabilities
uh with a team that actually launched
alexa back in 2013 2014
and my initial projects were you know
just getting myself warmed up with
natural language processing and i chose
that as my
area of focus for last four years
and it was uh over the last one one and
a half year that
we explicitly started focusing on
privacy and fairness
i completed my phd in electrical
engineering from university of southern
california
in 2016. uh there my focus was on
modeling human communication and
developing
computational models that can capture
the dynamics of human interaction
uh and uh that did connect well uh uh
with
what alexa was doing and that that
motivated me to take up a job uh here at
alex lab where
i focus on nlp uh
i'd like to also speak why i think
fairness is uh important
for researchers like myself i see that
ai has been becoming an integral part of
our society
and it has a big impact on our
day-to-day lives
and specifically when it comes to
agents like alexa i see it as
sort of like the next uh revolution just
like the internet
revolution or mobile phone revolution so
it's
it's going to have you know a big
influence on what we do in our daily
lives
so it is very important uh for that we
uh place individuals at the center of
any ai centric
uh development and if we are to do that
fairness becomes
a very important consideration because
we have to make sure that uh
ai works for uh everyone
thanks rahul um hello everyone i am
joala tamala i am a research scientist
at
amazon and i'm part of the alexa
trustworthy team where
rahul is a manager and in my team i work
on fairness interpretability and
robustness of natural
language understanding models i joined
amazon about a year ago and before that
i was a phd student at rit
where i was looking into how we can
combine
physics-based simulators with
data-driven machine learning
or deep learning models so i was also
looking into
the uncertainty in this both kind of
models and how
they propagate to our decision making
and i was
working into different active learning
techniques as well
so all of these closely relates are is
very important component in
fairness in ai as well and so
i have been using everything that i've
learned before in
ai research at amazon apart from
fairness in ai itself being a very
important topic
i'm also very interested and curious
about
ai in fairness in ai because
as human we are we can very easily
understand or
in a written form of a text or when
someone speaks or when we are speaking
converse in a conversation that
something is unfair
or harmful it's unpleasant
and how we need to handle it but our
systems are very far from those
capabilities so
um i'm very curious and interested to
find mathematical
or algorithmic ways to incorporate this
kind of
knowledge and intuition that we have and
we use in our daily life into
ai systems
uh thanks joella um hi everyone my name
is krishna ram kintapadi
i am a principal's uh scientist in
amazon web services submission
team uh leading our efforts on fairness
explainability and previous related
topics
i joined amazon about a year back and
before that was part of
microsoft research and linkedin a teams
so during my phd i focused on
models and algorithms for data privacy
uh including
an early work on differential privacy uh
since then i have been doing
more applied research on topics such as
data mining for web search recommended
systems
computational education and and more
recently on
topics related to fairness privacy and
explainability
in machine learning systems in practice
in addition to
what our panelists have already said i
am
excited about fairness also because it's
a socio-technical
construct so this means that uh we need
to collaborate with
all stakeholders involved get their
inputs
and also achieve consensus on what are
the desired fairness notions for
us as a society and also for the
specific applications that we are
considering
so that's what makes me really excited
about this
field the field of fairness in air in
general
wonderful thank you all i appreciate
that introduction i'm sure the
audience does as well so i know just to
start we mentioned the word fairness a
lot
so let's frame what we mean by fairness
in this conversation
uh so my question is how do you define
the term fairness
what's your perspective on the topic and
how has that informed your work
at amazon so i can i can start off
and let me start by saying i think it's
dangerous to try to
define you know for once and for all
what fairness is because as i'll
mention in a moment when it comes to
thinking about fairness
and unfairness in machine learning
systems you know we can't
speak using the same kind of richness of
language that say philosophers do
we have to you know confine ourselves to
sort of quantifiable metrics
and um we don't want to fool ourselves
into thinking that these sort of
quantifiable metrics are like capturing
fairness writ large i think at best we
should think of these as
sort of signs of unfairness we can flag
particular things that are going wrong
we shouldn't think of these as sort of
certifying that everything is going
right and the reason why we have to
think about
quantifiable metrics is because the way
machine learning works
is by optimizing a very narrow
objective function generally you've got
some data set you've got some objective
function which is usually some proxy for
classification accuracy
and you search through some huge space
of models to find the model that does
that the best
as measured according to your objective
function and the result is that you can
be pretty confident that the model that
you get back
is good as measured according to your
objective function
but it's very difficult to predict what
it's going to do in any way that is not
exactly aligned with the thing that you
set out to optimize like classification
accuracy
so for example um you know
you might get a model that has very
different error rates on different
populations it might in fact make
make errors that are sort of in a
harmful direction
in one population and and more in that
in the sort of
beneficial direction of the other
population for example in a credit
application we might be
disproportionately making
false positives for one population and
falls negatives for another
and in many of the high profile
instances we've seen you know in the
popular press of
deployed algorithms that are doing
things that are unfair
on the parts of the algorithm designers
who are typically following sort of
standard machine learning procedure
rather what happened was sort of the
unexpected and unanticipated side effect
of this sort of standard optimization
pipeline
okay and so that is all to say although
it's
important to have like ethical
scientists and software engineers that
is not sufficient a lot of the
unfairness we see in the wild is
unanticipated
and to address that we need to
you know think about changing our
training pipelines our evaluation
pipelines to explicitly constrain away
these kinds of behaviors that
we don't want to see and because these
are mathematical optimizations of course
to do that
we have to we have to think about these
sort of um
relatively narrow quantifiable metrics
so
the kinds of things we can do which are
of course not solving the fairness
problem
or we can just do our due diligence to
make sure that we are not seeing
sort of mistakes say of a harmful sort
disproportionately in one population
over another
and that's context dependent what you
know what are the harms done by machine
learning
but that's the kind of thing you need to
think about
when you're trying to decide whether you
know there's
a fairness problem with the technology
that you're thinking about deploying
tomorrow
now of course in the you know five to
ten year uh
time frame which is what i sort of you
know like to have fun thinking about as
a
as a professor um you know i think we
can get better at this i think we can
start learning how to think about not
just the
immediate consequences of our deployed
technologies but of their downstream and
upstream effects and
we don't really know how to do this well
just yet but
sort of that's part of that's part of
the goal going forward and if we can do
that
that'll give us i think a much better
grasp on
you know positive fairness as opposed to
just identifying clear signs of
unfairness
uh thanks aaron i can speak about
my experience with definitions of
fairness in natural language
understanding
domain so in natural language
understanding our data is primarily
text and sometimes images associated
with text so we
try to label our model being fair or
biased based on how it is
interpreting textual data or how it has
learned representation from
textual data so um language is a very
complex things
a same language in in a different
context it could mean sarcasm in
another context that the same sentence
could mean something else
um it can come convey complex
hierarchies social structure and
emotions of a person so uh as aaron
mentioned it's very difficult to come up
with one definition and say that
this is fairness in natural language
understanding so
also in the research community and in
the field i see that uh
different papers follow different
definitions based on their context and i
have seen
studies like uh people are trying to see
if certain general neutral professions
are associated with particular gender by
the model or
things like whether the model performs
similarly for different population group
from different
racial groups from the gender group or
it could even be certain ideas
people have also tried to look into
different
emotion emotional context content in a
text
whether it's conveying a certain
sentiment or toxicity or not
um but in general as a research
scientist at amazon
um i i really think that two things are
very important
when we come up with definitions of
fairness one being
that the definition should be grounded
to how
this definition impacts the end user so
if we are able to achieve the
definitions how will our
user or certain group of people benefit
by this
by achieving this and how will it
negatively impact other group of people
so
definitely one very important aspect as
a research scientist at amazon is to be
careful and consider the users
end users experience when using the
technology
with the definition we have used and
another thing
which is also very important and i use
it in my work is
to and to borrow ideas and
um be aligned with the research in other
disciplines like
there has been a lot of research in uh
sociolinguistic for example studying the
biases and language and how languages
can convey fairness and biases and
social hierarchy so we need to
also be aware of those research and
focus our definition on those there are
other fields including human computer
interaction
social psychology and i think we need to
ground our definition on those as well
yeah i agree thanks so much you all uh
for that
both of you um so it's interesting we
have
quite a diverse team of expertise on
this panel here today
with representation from different parts
of amazon
and different areas of research even
i like to understand from each of you
where your entries lie
and maybe how your current role or work
has shaped
your specific focus uh so erin
you co-authored a book with a fellow
professor in amazon scholar
michael kearns called the ethical
algorithm
the science of socially aware algorithm
design
and you also co-authored the algorithmic
foundations
of differential privacy with cynthia to
work
i wonder if you can give us a summary of
the topics
those books cover and what's changed or
evolved on these topics since
sure yeah so back in 2014 i wrote this
very technical book about differential
privacy with with cynthia dwork
and just last year i wrote a much more
general audience book with
with fellow amazon scholar michael
kearns called the ethical algorithm
and the ethical algorithm tries to first
start by explaining how problems arise
problems
of the sorts that we might typically
think of as
social or value driven so this is
concerns about privacy
but also fairness and interpretability
things like this um
and we try both to sort of point out how
these problems can arise
from the standard uh machine learning
optimization pipeline
but then also um
sort of make legible hopefully to a
broad audience
the emerging science that is coming out
of um
communities like the the fact community
and
and
a lot of work that appears here at
nurips um
thinking about how to make algorithm how
to design algorithms that are that are
better behaved that are sort of
more private or more fair um and we said
so we spend
uh a chapter you know surveying i think
the basics of the scientific literature
in in each of these areas privacy
fairness uh
the algorithmic game theory it's
important to think about users not just
algorithms
and the interactions between users are
often best understood
with with the technology of game theory
um we talk about
things that are important but less well
understood like interpretability you
know be good if someone came up with a
good definition for what that meant
in terms of what's changed um you know
when i wrote the
privacy book with cynthia differential
privacy was sort of a
an academic topic it was something that
you know mainly people like
write mathematical papers about and the
audience was you know maybe
15 other people like me um but in the in
the six years
since that have passed it's become you
know a real deployed technology and
since it was published it's been
deployed at big tech companies including
at amazon
it's been deployed as part of the us
2020 census and so it's become a real
technology
and things seem to be moving much more
quickly for
for algorithmic fairness so when when we
publish the ethical algorithm
you know already you know lots of the
lots of the energy was sort of centered
at
tech companies i think in the years
since it's been published um
you know the these technologies as you
know rudimentary as they
currently are have already um quickly
made their way
from from whiteboard to deployment and
it's sort of
exciting um seeing that happen and
seeing the
challenges that practice uh highlights
so christian ram you've spoken
in the past specifically about
explainability
and privacy in ai and ml systems
where does that fit into the scope of
the broader fairness and ar discussion
and what have you been working on in
this space
no thanks natalie um so as i haven't
mentioned though
these topics are very closely related um
so
for one they are socio-technical so
in other words their topics at the
intersection of boots society and
technology
this means that the challenges in these
topics cannot be addressed by
technologies alone we need to work with
various stakeholders these could be the
customers of a technology
or this could be people who are impacted
by a technology
as well as people with background in
ethics related disciplines
and we have to take all the inputs in
while
deciding or the the corresponding
systems
so that's one the second is that over
the last several years we have seen
there have been more and more uh
emerging social
expectations and also discussions on
these topics
in the context of building broadly
responsible ai
systems the third is even from a
regulatory angle
recent regulations such as european
unions global data protection regulation
or gdpr
and subsequent regulations such as
california's
consumer privacy act discuss all these
dimensions together
there are also a few uh nuances as aaron
mentioned
these topics are at different stages in
terms of their
technical development if we say poll
an audience in a group we may all agree
that the protecting privacy of
users is very important but we may not
necessarily
have consensus on what's the notion of
fairness perhaps because
there may not be a single notion of
fairness and there are also several
different
uh fairness notions proposed
in the literature so i have been uh
doing research on these topics and also
helping
build and deploy systems in practice so
this is something that really excites me
taking
uh being at the intersection of the
research and practice and helping
having worked on applications related to
web search
analytics hiring and so on so most
recently
uh since joining amazon i helped start
and uh leave this efforts
for amazon sage maker samsung sage maker
is a fully managed service that helps
every developer and data scientist to
build
train deploy and monitor machine
learning models
so what i am excited uh is to share that
we just launched amazon sagemaker
clarify
and are announced as part of aws
reinvent conference earlier this week
sage maker clarifies a new functionality
in sagemaker that helps detect potential
bias in machine learning models
and also explain predictions made by
these models
so using this functionality or data
scientists
and machine learning practitioners can
detect bias during
various stages for example during
training data preparation
once the models are trained and also
once the models are deployed
over time and then thereby they can take
corrective
actions as needed for that application
in addition sagemaker clarify also
includes tools
to help provide explanations of machine
learning models
as a whole and also the predictions made
by these models
yeah finally like we are also doing
research
on these dimensions often motivated by
practical or application settings so so
i'll give one example
so often uh sagemaker customers
may bring their own machine learning
training data and code
in a container and as a result we don't
have
the ability to modify the objective
function or incorporate
fairness constraints during model
training
in our recent paper we showed that
how we can achieve both accurate and uh
fair models uh just by tuning the hyper
parameters
of these models uh making use of
bayesian optimization techniques so this
paper appeared
in the icml automl workshop
earlier this year it also received the
best paper award in that workshop
we also have ongoing research on several
related topics
for example how do we recent about
fairness in
human in the loop settings how do we
design algorithms to achieve
different notions of fairness as well as
privacy how do we
identify failure modes of machine
learning models and
also take corrective actions for those
so models and so on
thank you krishna rahm so
rahul as a scientist dedicated to voice
ai i imagine you have a unique
perspective
on the idea of fairness as voice ai
would have his own set of unique
challenges and considerations
can you share more on this
certainly naturally so as i was
mentioning earlier as well
you know these ai systems such as alexa
or the ones on your phone
or the ones in your car they are
becoming more and more in this
dispensable part of
our social fabric all these technologies
are actually reaching
people and they're becoming an integral
part of their
uh daily lives and therefore biased
mitigation and fairness is a is you know
it needs even
deeper attention so uh so
just to follow on on this sort of
philosophy uh
our goal uh at alexa is to make sure
that you know our
technology it works equally well for all
our customers from
different backgrounds uh you know
different cultures
and different ethnicities and so forth
an important challenge when designing
these
voice based systems is alongside all the
challenges that any machine learning
system has
is voice-based systems they often
operate in a pipeline so uh
uh now just to give an example here
what you may have is a large machine
learning system such as
asr speech recognition
setting mode up front and then that
feeds into downstream
uh components such as a natural language
processing component which
actually tries to understand uh what the
user meant
uh based upon the text that the asr
module fed to it
and then there could be downstream
components which actually construct a
response to the user and return it back
to the user
so it's a fairly complex system and it's
uh it's something that
stitched out of uh putting various uh
components together
uh and the challenge here could be you
know often it could happen that
these systems are designed uh in silo or
they could be designed together as well
but if they are designed in silo uh
there could be a bias propagation
happen from an upstream component to a
downstream component
so there's this additive challenge of
making sure that all of your
individual components are robust to bias
that can
flow in from some of these uh upstream
machine learning models
and uh so that that's my first you know
that's just one unique challenge there
are more
uh but i'll sort of you know just focus
on this one
and uh i'd also like to mention that we
are also cognizant of the fact that you
know voice agents have become
have started to become an integral part
of our daily lives you can find
uh them in our cars phones even our
homes right now
so uh one other thing that i am really
excited to see and i'm really happy to
uh observe is you know uh uh
we are sort of interacting with a lot of
stakeholders and making sure that
uh you know we are doing the right
things uh so that's really great to see
um and uh you know we are focusing on
making sure that we offer this equitable
experiences
to the customer and we are also
interested in seeing how we can actually
stop the
propagation of buyers that are
historically propagated
so these are all of these are important
considerations that
we keep in mind when we design a voice
agent like alexa
got it thanks so much so jawala
you worked on some experiments and use
cases
uh related to fairness and ai in your
role um can you tell us more
yeah sure and ashley so um our team has
worked on multiple
use cases related to fairness but let me
focus on one
recent work that is currently in
summation at the conference
so in this work we our team was
interested in investigating bias in
an open-ended language generation
problem and
this is very important because many uh
nlp tasks now
use uh natural language generation
models as one of their central building
blocks so
to quantify bias in this model to
benchmark biases
before using them in downstream tasks is
very
critical to ensure that our models are
bias free
so what we did in this paper or in this
research work is um
mainly uh we could talk about it in two
categories our first is we wanted to
design or
come up with a large benchmark data set
that can be used by
researcher or industry practitioner to
benchmark their language generation
model
and second was we worked on coming up
coming up with a set of
evaluation metrics to evaluate bias in
the model so
let me talk a little bit about the
dataset and how we
uh collected those dataset um so uh in
terms of
dataset uh our aim was that the datasets
should be large enough diverse enough
comprehensive enough to capture
biases in various situations or across
different
population groups or even across
different ideologies
uh also we wanted the data sets to be
large enough so that we can uh simulate
what our system may be
exposed to when deployed in practice so
uh
for that we use wikipedia as our data
source so what we would do is we would
um
select a set of wikipedia pages we would
crawl into the wikipedia page and
select um a set of uh sentence
track set of sentence beginning let's
say uh seven eight words from each
sentences and
uh uh add them to our data set and uh
in this way we collected our data set
that had more than 20
000 such prompt uh those prompts are
uh can be used as context to a language
generation model so let's say
we have a set of awards that uh describe
or talk about certain
uh religion and another set of words uh
are prompts that talk about another
religion so if we ask a language
generation model to generate given these
two sets of uh prompt we will be able to
compare and study
if there is biases in how this model
generate given the problems or context
from these various uh religions
so that that's what the dataset consists
of and uh in terms of evaluation metric
uh
as we mentioned uh earlier it's very
difficult to come up with one metric to
capture different kind of biases in
uh nlp tasks uh also um um
it's it's very difficult to come up with
a
concrete definition that will capture or
is comprehensive enough to capture all
kind of biases so
um we uh broadly defined uh fairness in
our task as uh if a model generates
uh negative uh sentiments or negative
uh sentences that is harmful to a
certain population group more frequently
than for
other than the model will be considered
biased and so we
came up with a set of metrics including
things like sentiments of toxicity
gender polarity and and many more so
we did the evaluation on those uh based
on those metrics
so in overall uh in this paper we uh
key takeaways were that um among the
different models we tried like gpt2
bird control models we saw that there
was a signa
they were generating uh sentences with
biases more frequently than our baseline
of
wikipedia sentences themselves uh and
also we saw that uh the control
model with uh certain control codes were
generating more
uh more frequently this kind of
sentences so
uh our dataset was not aimed to
explicitly extract certain kind of
biases it was comprehensive and it was
designed to simulate a real world
situation and so
uh it's a very it was a very alarming
result for us to see this kind of biases
in the model and
moving forward our aim is to study how
these spices propagate in downstream
tasks as well as how we can mitigate the
biases before they are
used with a real world system
thanks to all of that that makes sense
so
i guess to close uh i'm interested in
gathering insights from this group on
what's in store for the future
uh where do you see the ai community
focusing efforts
and how are we tackling this important
topic
um let me give you some
thoughts on this topic um so if you
think of fairness in
ai or responsibly more broadly
it's a very timely challenge for the
society that
we all have the opportunity to address
and
to do research and to work on um so
clearly this is not a challenge
limited to any one company or even
the tech industry as a whole um so
because of this reason we have been now
partnering with the
academic researchers our peer companies
and the broader community
so for example we have been working with
the partnership on ai
to help draft guidelines and best
practices on these topics
uh we have also been um engaging with
the academy through
amazon research awards on related topics
um through internships and also
collaborations with professors
this is something that uh i'm very
excited about to
collaborate even more with the various
professors and their students
so personally uh i'm excited about
being at the intersection of the
academia and industry
um and have been presenting tutorials on
topics like uh privacy industries
fairness
or explainability in industry
responsibility in industry and so on
jointly with collaborators from other
peer companies so that we
share our collective experience present
the
open challenges research challenges that
we are seeing
in the industry in this space and
thereby also help drive collaboration
with the academic researchers
so finally let me uh note that
it's very important to build an
inclusive
and diverse research community on these
topics
so because of the uh significant
societal
implications of these disciplines we
need diversity in terms of
demographics uh lived experience
perspectives
expertise and so on and
uh really thankful that
we have several cross disciplinary
conferences uh such as the
asean conference on fairness
transparency
fairness accountability and transparency
um as well as the
aaa acm conference on the artificial
intelligence ethics and society
where we see researchers not just from
computer science but also from
other disciplines and thereby through
this cross-pollination of research we
are seeing
the right primitives or the right
notions
on these topics starting to emerge this
is what
keeps me really excited about these
areas
yes i'd like to uh second uh krishna i'm
there it is really exciting
and great to see all the acceleration in
fairness research
and uh it's actually making all the way
uh into you know
industrial systems it's having a real uh
real life impact
uh and it's changing how ml systems uh
are built at scale
and we ourselves my team and myself have
benefited from
such a collaboration uh emphasis now
lies in making sure that
the research that happens in the
academic setting quickly finds its way
into production and
the time lag between two is minimized
and as krishna mentioned
there are all these platforms that help
us get connected
uh as as a
researcher you know we benefit a lot
attending some of these conferences
which are specifically focused on
fairness and we ourselves would be
actually organizing
a workshop at north american chapter of
acl and we
uh hope to learn a lot from from that
workshop
i'd also like to point out that a closer
collaboration between industry and
academia has
uh uh paved the way for you know all
this progress to happen
and it's also uh uh an interesting
observation here that
the industry is making inroads uh by
consulting policy makers when it comes
to fairness research and its
implementation so
it's becoming a bigger community we are
getting uh tightly
net more and more and i i am very uh
hopeful about the
uh of uh of this uh this research
because of all this collaboration
i can go um so of course it's uh
hard to predict what things will look
like in five or ten years
but i would urge people to maybe look
beyond the standard
um machine learning conferences and
you know as in any hot field although
there's been a lot of work in fairness
and machine learning
not all of it has been the most uh
thoughtful and coherent
but there is this sort of steady stream
of work that tends to come out of
um things like the theoretical computer
science community
and and in fact there's a whole um
theory conference uh called foundations
of responsible computing that
that i helped start last year and this
is going to continue again this year
which some of this work is happening
that is trying to think about
um let's say more principled approaches
to thinking about fairness
and an obstacle to lots of
it's often the case that these more
principled approaches have
serious obstacles to deployment which um
is why we don't see more of this
um but i think we should remember that
with something like differential privacy
which is now
you know a widely deployed technology
you know it took 10 years for for the
transition from from the whiteboard to
to a real technology and i'm hopeful
that in the next
five or 10 years we'll start to see
payoff from some of this more principled
theoretical research and that some of
these more sort of foundational ideas
will start to to see their way into
practice
yeah so uh then really quickly before we
go uh amazon also has a collaboration
with the nsf on fairness and ai efforts
can you speak to the importance of the
nsf
uh in this space and how it's helping
drive
improvements in fairness and ai
here ashley i can take that question so
actually a year ago amazon
and a national science foundation
announced a 20 million dollar
collaboration
to fund academic research on fairness in
ai over a three year period
so this was a great thing that started
last year the goal of this collaboration
is to promote academic research
and this important aspect of ai our
primary objective for engaging with
academia
on issues related to fairness and
transparency in aia
is to get many different and diverse
perspective focused on the challenge
so uh the the first 10 recipients
uh of grant issued projects at the
itascore broad research areas
the first one was ensuring fairness
algorithms and the system that
incorporate them
which begins with the definition and
quantification of fairness and i guess
we talked about that a little bit uh in
this uh
in this conversation the second one was
accountability and transparency in ai
algorithms
third one using ai to promote equity
in society and finally the fourth one
was ensuring that the benefits of ai
are available to everyone
so what we hope in the future is that
the future cycles of research will build
upon the success of the first round
by bringing an even greater diversity of
perspectives on definition
and perceptions of fairness
wonderful i want to thank you all for
sharing your insights on this important
topic
of fairness and ai for those who have
tuned into the session
we invite you to reach out to us to
discuss our research
efforts or experience working with
amazon
one-on-one i'll also mention you can
read more about
the winning grants and amazon's
collaboration
with the national science foundation as
well as various fairness and ai blog
posts and articles
on amazon.science website
so again thank you all for tuning in
hope you have a good one